I'm going to start with a
story in 1730 in India the king of jpo
wanted to build a new Palace and he
needed a large number of trees to be cut
alarmed at hearing this a group of local
environmental activists went to protect
the trees by throwing their arms around
them we could consider them the first
ever Tree
Huggers now while this story might be
known to many of us what's often less
known is what motivated these
activists they came from the bishnoi
community a Hindu lineage founded on 29
principles of environmental care this is
just one of so many amazing examples
throughout the world of religious
communities stepping up to protect the
environment through through addressing
climate change restoring ecosystems and
protecting
biodiversity and I've had the honor and
the privilege of working with many such
groups in different parts of the world
for environmental action but before I
did that I actually was living in India
where I spent time in a Hindu ashram on
the banks of the Sacred River Ganges
where I was studying Hindu
spirituality and how the teachings of
the Bhagavad Gita could be applied to
contemporary concerns in the world and
it was through this orientation of an
Engaged religion and
spirituality that brought me to The
Climate movement in
2010 and since then I think like many of
us I have experienced the highs and the
lows as we've campaigned and advocated
to keep Global temperature increase to
1.5° and I don't know about you but I
think right now it can feel like it's a
difficult time to be working on climate
change sometimes things just don't seem
to be moving as quickly as we would like
and more often than not unfortunately we
might be feeling scared or stuck
hopeless or maybe even burnt out coming
from the faith sector I've always been
interested in are there ideas that are
rooted in religion and spirituality that
can support the broader environmental
movement I started looking into the
history of religious and spiritual
groups and started thinking that they
could be some of the most enduring
social movements in the history of the
world they've been able to survive
through multiple Generations adapt to
changing situations reform and revive
themselves when needed they've even
inspired the leaders of some of the most
iconic social movements in recent
history such as Mahatma Gandhi and
Martin Luther King Jr that's why I was
really happy when a friend of of mine
who was writing a book about Hindu
approaches to pastoral care asked me to
contribute a chapter using my previous
background as a university chaplain I
developed a framework that I thought
could help people suffering from climate
trauma and as I went around sharing this
framework with people from different
backgrounds they told me that it really
resonated with them the framework
although initially built for climate
trauma I think can really help with
something I believe we need now in the
climate movement building resiliency and
keeping
momentum there are three core
interconnected parts to this framework
that are drawn from across a variety of
religious and spiritual Traditions I'm
excited to share that with you and I'm
going to use the Sanskrit words to
explain the different aspects of the
framework we begin with suer nourishing
and uplifting Community where people
come together to support one another and
reaffirm social ties this can happen
weekly monthly or at different times of
the year so for example my Christian
friends they go to church on a Sunday my
Muslim friends go to prayer on a Friday
and my Hindu friends they will gather at
Major festivals such as Dali we then
have stener rituals and traditions that
give us a sense of belong longing this
can often be fasting at times of the
year or going on pilgrimage or retelling
stories that have been passed down for
multiple
Generations Buddhists will go on
pilgrimage to Gaia where the Buddha
found
Enlightenment Jewish families and
communities will retell the stories of
their ancestors when they gather for
their
holidays and then we have Savor
purposeful action these groups have
guidance and teachings for how to show
up in the world how to care for one
another and the planet in the Jane
tradition there is a focus on leading a
life based on
nonviolence members of the bahai faith
are encouraged to be anxiously concerned
with the needs of the world we do these
things on a regular basis but there are
two ways that religious and spiritual
groups engage in these practices that
set them slightly aart the first is
intention when religious and spiritual
groups engage in these practices they do
them with a sense of importance
recognize that these are core functions
of what it means to be part of that
group let's let's illustrate that with
an example from the climate movement
let's look at the Fridays for future
School
strike that was an example where some
real focused intention yielded amazing
results by perform performing a very
simple activity not going to school on
Fridays they were able to build a
community a simple ritual and a
purposeful action and by doing so they
built resiliency amongst themselves and
motivated millions of people around the
world that change was
possible now if we bring these three
practices together along with the
intention something really magical
starts to
happen this is the second special
feature that religious and spiritual
groups bring to these practices it's
something that provides the ultimate
grounding narrative and meaning for why
Community rituals and action are
important I call it the big
idea for religious and spiritual groups
the big idea is often a sense of the
Divine of God or a metaphysical
understanding of the world or a grand
Narrative of a people throughout time
whatever it is the big idea usually has
some common characteristics to it it's
usually something that has existed
before us and will exist after us the
big idea is not limited to a certain
moment time or
place now I'm getting some worried looks
in the audience don't worry I'm not
asking all of us to go out there and
start looking for God but I am
suggesting that we may benefit from
being part of something bigger than
ourselves and that can take many
different
forms for many people I meet in the
climate movement their big idea is being
part of and connected to Nature and
appreciating the beauty of the natural
world but it can also be a sense of
connection we feel to our ancestors and
the responsibility we have to Future
Generations it can also be a sense of of
wonder about the world space and all
that
exists or yes the big idea could be a
belief in something bigger than
ourselves that we can't quiet fully
understand but the presence of which we
feel from time to
time the big idea the intention and
these three
practices when coming together are
extremely powerful and are bigger than
the sum of their parts
for me my big idea is that the Earth is
a
goddess in Sanskrit she is called
boomi she is the lifegiving source that
nourishes me and all that
exists in order to sustain this idea I
make sure I have a community of people
around me who believe similarly every
morning I have a simple ritual where I
offer her My Worship than thanking her
for all that she provides and I try to
show up in the world with meaningful
action treating her with the love
respect and compassion that she
deserves as we stand in this moment of
time
together with all of the data and
science before
us I believe we need to equip ourselves
with every tool and resource
possible my invitation to all of us is
that we all find our big idea and create
communities rituals and practices with
renewed intention and
purpose this framework not only has the
potential to help us build resiliency
and
momentum but it can profoundly transform
the world it has worked for people and
communities for thousands of
years and perhaps
it could work for us now thank
you